questo
è il giocattolo preferito di mia figlia
quando era piccola
Io sono solito ero solito acquistare
oggetti giocattoli di seconda mano
perché questo non è proprio lo stesso
giocattolo Ma gli assomiglia molto
perché l'ho comprato un paio di
settimane fa in un negozio dell'usato di
quelli specializzati per l'infanzia che
vanno oggi tanto di moda lei passava le
ore con le torte
i biscotti e faceva il caffè
e io chiedevo loro alle mie figlie di
trattare bene i giocattoli gli abitini e
le attrezzature che le regalavamo che
gli regala gli regalavamo Perché
potevamo dare loro a questi giochi a
queste attrezzature l'opportunità di
regalare una seconda vita
portandoli in un negozio dell'usato e
facendo rivivere l'oggetto nelle mani di
un altro bimbo
mia mamma
non era d'accordo e mi diceva Ma
possibile che non puoi permetterti di
comprare una cosa nuova per tua figlia
Io
ovviamente
le chiedevo le dicevo quanto era
importante il
secondo end il gioco
ma lei mi incalzava mi diceva possibile
è veramente impossibile che tu non possa
comprare qualcosa di nuovo lei non era
mai entrata in un negozio dell'usato se
ne vergognava
questa cosa mi fece capire che
probabilmente c'è un problema di
percezione Perché molte persone
percepiscono un oggetto usato in maniera
differente l'una dall'altra Io di
mestiere faccio l'imprenditore e apro un
negozio dell'usato in Italia ci sono
circa 3000 negozi dell'usato Dove si
possono portare in vendita delle cose
lasciarle in vendita e alla vendita
incassare il corrispettivo della vendita
ho quindi elaborato e abbiamo studiato
con il nostro scollo staff una mappa di
percezione dell'usato
eccola qui
l'usato per una persona
può essere inserita nel mondo del
rifiuto Quindi io la posso equiparare
alla spazzatura a un qualcosa di rotto a
un qualcosa che non serve più
e che non è possibile riutilizzare
ma posso anche decidere di collocarlo in
quella nell'area cip nell'area economica
nell'area della povertà Io compro usato
perché nuovo non me lo posso permettere
ma abbiamo un'altra bellissima area che
l'area della scoperta che è quella che
attira tantissime persone nei mercatini
dell'usato di piazza la possibilità di
scoprire un qualcosa di cui non si
conosceva l'esistenza
un'altra area molto bella è l'area del
ricordo
l'area che ci connette alla nostra
infanzia Io ricordo che andai in un
mercatino dell'usato e trovai una
sveglia di quelle meccaniche dove c'era
una gallina che beccava mano a mano che
l'orologio che la sveglia segnava le ore
L'ho comprata la comprai perché la
stessa identica sveglia era sul comodino
di mia nonna
poi c'è l'area a quella che preferisco
l'area Smart l'area delle persone un
pochino
furbe No perché dice che a parità di
prezzo un oggetto di seconda mano ha una
qualità molto superiore
perché se io ho 50 euro in tasca e
voglio comprare un cappotto posso
decidere di comprarlo nuovo vado in un
negozio lo acquisto nuovo ma posso fare
una scelta intelligente e andare in un
negozio dell'usato e con gli stessi
soldi comprare un capo un cappotto di
qualità molto più elevata
tante persone poi
sposano la second Hand Economy il mondo
dell'usato perché è sostenibile perché
allunga il ciclo di vita di un prodotto
diminuisce i rifiuti e Evita la
produzione dei corrispondenti articoli
nuovi e poi c'è infine l'area Elite
l'area quella del modernariato del
vintage dell'oggetto di design che
vengono dal passato
ad esempio
vi ricorderete tutti il calcio che ha
dato Totti a fine carriera al suo
pallone
firmato l'ha preso un ragazzo questo
ragazzo si chiama Thomas e gli hanno
offerto delle cifre pazzesche per
riuscire a comprare questo pallone usato
e lui ha sempre detto
non ha prezzo questo pallone per me è
sacro
Ecco E ora che siete esperti della mappa
di percezione potete capire Mia mamma
dove collocava gli oggetti usati perché
ovviamente li collocava nell'area del
rifiuto io quando l'ho scoperto ho
iniziato a prenderla in giro eravamo al
ristorante lei stava mangiando e le
chiesi Ma scusa mamma ma quella
forchetta è nuova oppure è usata Lei mi
guardava mi diceva Sì vabbè ma ho capito
è lavata Ah è lavata ma e quando
andavamo in hotel che eravamo in vacanza
i materassi ce li portavamo da casa o
usavamo quelli in dotazione
e lei ogni volta mi tacciava dicendo Sì
ma tu sei un idealista
e io ovviamente rimanevo nella mia
percezione e lei rimaneva nella sua
ovviamente mia figlia
inseriva gli oggetti usati in un
contesto completamente diverso
Considerate che i ragazzi oggi il 65%
dei ragazzi compra e vende abitualmente
oggetti usati
per loro non è un tabù per loro non è
uno stigma l'usato loro partono dal
presupposto che il consumismo è un
qualcosa del passato non hanno avuto la
pressione che hanno avuto le generazioni
come la mia sul consumismo e quindi non
c'è il pensiero di dover produrre un
oggetto con l'obiettivo di farlo
diventare un rifiuto nel più breve tempo
possibile perché questa era crescita
Questa era ricchezza
i ragazzi di oggi hanno compreso e
stanno comprendendo l'importanza del
mondo dell'usato
E da qui Se voi Guardate in giro Vedete
un fiorire di attività che si basano sul
mondo dell'usato mercatini dell'usato
negozi dell'usato mercatini di piazza
applicazione sul cellulare che vi
permettono di connettervi con altre
persone comprare o vendere usa per
comprare o vendere oggetti di seconda
mano
pensate a cosa può succedere a livello
di sostenibilità nel momento in cui noi
ci rivolgiamo ad un negozio dell'usato
perché abbiamo una sostenibilità di tipo
ambientale andiamo ad allungare il ciclo
di vita di un prodotto riduciamo il
numero di rifiuti evitiamo che sia
prodotto il corrispondente articolo
nuovo
ma non solo abbiamo una sostenibilità di
tipo economico Perché i negozi
dell'usato sono attività che pagano
tasse che assumono persone e rivolgersi
ad un negozio dell'usato significa
contribuire a mantenere quel tessuto di
microimprese che sono spesso di
carattere familiare che caratterizzano
la nostra economia
ed infine l'attività del mondo
dell'usato porta anche a un beneficio è
una sostenibilità di tipo sociale dove
viene In un certo qual modo ridisegnato
il sesto il senso del possesso io
acquisto un bene lo utilizzo ne smetto
l'utilizzo lo rivendo e recupero parte
dell'investimento
e quindi
questo gioco
poteva rimanere in mano a mia figlia poi
andare in cantina o andare in garage o
andare in soffitta ad impolverarsi
Oppure avrebbe potuto come è stato fatto
rivivere una nuova vita nelle mani di un
altro bimbo attraverso un negozio
dell'usato Ecco che io oggi vi esorto
arrivati a casa Aprite i vostri armadi
andate in solaio andate in garage e
contate quanti oggetti ancora nuovi
ancora in buono stato ai quali potreste
Donare una seconda vita prendeteli e
portateli in vendita in un negozio
dell'usato
[Applauso]